grazie una notizia cattiva sono l'ultima
conferenza
una notizia buona sono l'ultima
conferenza io sono felice di essere qua
sono felice io sono pazzo per te infatti
adesso mi sento un po dentro dello
schermo di youtube
io sono argentino quindi parlo
l'italiano come il papà l'hanno detto
anche come un calciatore anche come un
calciatore della serie a per fortuna non
sono della chiesa cattolica
parliamo che futuro e purtroppo non sono
un calciatore
questo è il mio lavoro il mio lavoro del
teatro io sono un appassionato un
innamorato del del teatro e faccio
teatro d'improvvisazione che si conosce
nel mondo come imprò questo tipo di
teatro si fa dappertutto si fa io l'anno
scorso sono stato in india
l'anno prossimo salone la germania si fa
in italia per su questo si fa la
settimana prossima sarà il messico sono
stato per fortuna viaggio troppo con il
mio inprotur per fortuna non ho un'altra
foto permettere quindi è tutto a posto
il nostro teatro c'entra tantissimo con
il il futuro il futuro che io chiamo il
primo futuro noi nella improvvisazione
non abbiamo copione non abbiamo nulla
prescritto
quindi noi dobbiamo buttarci via novi a
buttarci buttarci via volte sì al
pubblico lo chiede noi dobbiamo giocare
con quello che abbiamo noi non abbiamo
un futuro prescritto noi dobbiamo farlo
e questo è una cosa fantastica il
pubblico
arriva al teatro e non sa cosa faranno
gli attori
però noi neanche noi sappiamo io un'ora
prima del mio spettacolo non so cosa
farò
comincia lo spettacolo non so ancora
cosa farò
sono a metà dello spettacolo e non so
come finisce il mio spettacolo quindi ci
mette una sensazione di vita concentrata
con un colpo che il pubblico si mette in
questo gioco e il pubblico cerca di
metterci in difficoltà del fare delle
sfide e noi siamo lì nel vuoto nel
disequilibrio e tutti guardano vediamo
come per esempio facciamo una cosa
democratica
io posso continuare questa conferenza
questi minuti che mancano con delle
parole che ho imparato del testo scritto
posso continuare con una conferenza alla
scritta o scelta 2 posso continuare con
un'improvvisazione improvvisando
facciamo per favorire luce facciamo così
se vota per continuare con la conferenza
già scritta così con con la mano aperta
per improvvisare facciamo il vuoto
teneteli che faccio racconto va bene
98,9 per cento
c'era uno in deciso con l'epilessia non
lo so bene
beviamo questo in questi prossimi cinque
sette minuti
noi abbiamo scelto senza dubbio
improvvisare abbiamo scelto quello prima
che arrivare un porto sicuro con le
parole perché se il fatto di essere
sulla strada nuova
sul cammino nuovo ci mette in ansia
molto particolare se questo lo abbiamo
scelto per questi cinque minuti perché
dopo ci ostiniamo così tanto e tentare
scrivere un copione della nostra vita
siano cinque minuti
cinque anni perché dopo chi fa
improvvisazione porta questo al di là
del del palcoscenico
me ne andrò al palcoscenico grazie per
favore tu che alemanno così se io mi
muovo e ha certo punto più fai questo
bene e tu cosa ho qua un bastone va bene
e qua c'è un'altra cosa che non c'entra
nulla con un bastone questo per vedere
che stiamo improvvisando no cosa cosa è
qua una pentola una pentola per cucinare
grazia bene e questo è un esempio
perfetto io adesso il mio prossimo
futuro il mio primo futuro dipendere
questa pentola e questo vasto né se io
mi fermo a pensare forse preferivo una
macchina un uccello no l'improvvisatore
gioca va avanti al futuro con quello che
ha
nel presente avevamo il bastone abbiamo
la pentola
tutto pronto per il mio nipote cosa sto
cucinando nella pentola cosa fagioli
casa il fagioli per il mio nipote per
fortuna sto cucinando fagioli o un po di
sale è il compleanno del mio nipotino
arriva arriva da lontano ma adesso due
cose o una cosa qua in tasca che non
c'entra nulla con questa storia
cosa ho fatto un anello un'altra cosa
una smart phone
va bene per questo personaggio mi sembra
che non c'entra nulla
uno smartphone perfetto questo
personaggio ha uno smartphone e adesso
accade qualsiasi cosa imprevista
c'è un imprevisto cosa cosa accade che
non c'entra con la storia forse cosa
come il nono come va bene tutti vogliamo
improvvisare questo buono questo buono
cosa cosa di quadri qualche to della
seconda fila si va via la luce va bene
io non avevo visto luce però perfetto il
mio nipote anche loro improvvisano bene
siete bravi siete bravi io che ho la
cucina elettrica perché sono un nono
governo i fagioli diventano crudi sul
mio nipote
il mio nipote che è abbastanza arriva un
altro personaggio prima del nipote chi
arriva
gli alieni va bene va bene galieni non
posso dire di no il mio lavoro non posso
dire no sono alieni tipici sta
lievitando beviamo che io faccio questo
piccolo parentesi non sapevo cosa faceva
questo personaggio nuovo è questo questa
è la differenza più grande con il teatro
tradizionale diciamo il teatro detesto
dove se io sono attori che gioco il
ruolo di ambient gioco in inglese dicono
to play che più bello che recitare o che
tu hai una spagnola e anche dicono
camerino ambleto se io faccio ha detto
io so che nell'ultimo atto a mileto
muore
scusatemi lo spoiler però c'è un tempo
ma ma l'improvvisazione non so cosa fa
se questa improvvisazione se fa con due
tre attori io non ho la la testa il
pensiero dell'altro quindi questo che il
futuro mio sempre io ringrazio qualsiasi
qualsiasi avvenimento qualsiasi
imprevisto se io mi preparo per un
imprevisto non è un imprevisto e allora
io ringrazio questo alieno davvero
sto parlando un alieno cambio paolo in
italiano
sappiamo che tu fai e fagioli più
saporiti del mondo ti portiamo al nostro
pianeta che abbiamo visto nella
conferenza anteriore ti portiamo con noi
anche il fagiolo
lasciatemi un minuto così parlo con il
mio nipote no non ti lascio ti lasciamo
mio nipote mi faccio la self icone
l'alieno
il finale della storia e il finale della
storia
siccome siccome non improvvisazione non
abbiamo nulla
questo è un vantaggio per noi per noi
perché possiamo avere tutto quindi il
finale si vede la navicella dell'alieno
si vede tutto un bosco si sente anche il
vento nel vostro che fa facciamo un po
si sente bosco se va a questo rumore e
arriva al nipote e vede questo telefono
questa immagine per il cielo la
navicella che si va e nella sua lacrima
dice di end del finale della storia el
abbiamo fatto insieme
l'abbiamo fatto insieme questo del
telefono dello smartphone è una cosa che
forse prima era una cosa che sembrava
dimenticata ma l'improvvisatore lavora
nel futuro con la memoria perché una
grande parte dell'immaginazione e la
memoria e quindi riprendo questo
elemento e noi andiamo verso questo
primo futuro con la memoria di quello
che abbiamo senza giudicare io non penso
prima di uno spettacolo
vorrei questa questi vestiti vorrei che
il pubblico dica questa cosa quest'altra
io gioco con quello che c'è nel momento
c'è una frase in argentina che diceva il
presente e il futuro il presente e il
futuro che ieri ci preoccupava così
tanto il presente e il futuro che ieri
ci preoccupava così tanto noi gli
improvvisatori siamo pazzi per vivere il
futuro facendolo noi stesso con ogni
gesto con una risposta del pubblico con
ogni parola con ogni emozione tante
volte tante volte dice la gente che la
vita è come come una opera del teatro o
come un film e forse sia vero che la
vita sia come una lunga opera di teatro
ma siccome è impossibile è impossibile
avere un copione della nostra vita
io penso che la vita e dobbiamo essere
improvvisatori perché la vita che ci
aspetta è che viviamo è come una opera
di teatro ma come una operare teatro
d'improvvisazione tante grazie